- Hey guys, here at Wine Library,
just filming some wine
videos for the store.
But real quick, before
you go into today's vlog,
it is time to subscribe to my channel.
So many of you are not doing it.
Let me pull my, let me just
roll up for a solid right hook.
This is the opportunity.
Please, please, please subscribe.
Not sure exactly the UI.
It would mean the world to me.
Hope you enjoy today's vlog.
(energetic music)
(soft music)
- I need to run.
- Please, Gary.
- It was great to see you.
- Always great to see you.
- [Man] Hey, Gary.
Archie got you something
for your birthday.
- Thank you, Cesar!
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding!
I'm kidding.
- It's a t-shirt.
- I love it, man.
- Nothing fancy, but.
- Scooby-Doo.
Dude.
Nice job.
This is a very meaningful gift
because it's a very, very, very,
you have to be hardcore
fan, you have to know
a lot about me to know this.
My favorite cartoon is the Laugh Olympics
which is a cartoon that
like nobody knows existed.
First of all, it was a '70s cartoon.
I only saw it because
they replayed it on USA
and one of the, it's groups of cartoons
competing against each
other and one of the teams
was called the Scooby-Doobies
and this is what that is.
I love this.
Thank you, man.
I'm gonna definitely rock this.
Hey, vlog.
Going to a new partnership
meeting opportunity for PureWow
and Iris is breaking things.
We'll see you later.
(soft music)
What I think is when I
care about something,
I think I know how to hack culture
to make something relevant
that people actually start--
Has the disproportionate
ROI in my opinion for--
Where I feel passionate
about it from a standpoint
is actual business and I
think this is the engine
and the framework to
create a world where--
You know me.
I'm a disrupter that's practical.
I know for fact that I--
I just know that for fact.
Just had a crazy call with a client.
Big time stuff.
Iris, you'll figure out how
to beep 98 percent of it.
Use some things that meant nothing
but giving you guys context,
just trying to close
a multimillion dollar deal.
We don't show this part of me
but show from the beginning,
timestamp it, would you?
- [Iris] Okay.
- I'll give you guys the preview.
Actually, may not even need the timestamp.
It was a 30 minute call exactly.
These are things I want to show more of.
I just spent 30 minutes trying to tell
one of the biggest brains in the world
to do a sponsorship thing in
the gallery, the PureWow world.
It would be millions
of dollars in revenue.
This is what I do when you don't see me.
You don't build 150
million dollar businesses--
- Yeah, work it.
- Selling sneakers.
So, building businesses.
(soft music)
Your card meant a lot to me.
- [Iris] Of course.
- I'm so happy the way it all worked out.
What a missed opportunity
it would have been
for both of us if you'd left.
I'm so glad you came to that realization.
You're such a special girl,
we're gonna do so well together.
I'm gonna help you so much.
It's like the best decision you ever made.
- [Iris] Yeah.
It really came from the heart.
Before I came here, you really
really helped me a lot, so.
Before I came here, when I was back home.
- Yep.
- My mom and everything.
- [Iris] During that time,
it was really difficult
but I would, seriously,
I would watch your stuff
and listen to everything,
like wow, it was really hard.
- Yeah.
- [Iris] But for some
reason, my listening to you,
it really, really helped
me get through it.
- I know.
Listen, anybody who picks up--
- [Iris] And that's one of the reasons
why I really believe in you.
(Gary laughs)
Because, you know--
- You lived it.
- [Iris] Yeah, and so--
- But then to be able
to come in the inside--
- [Iris] I know.
- And actually see how real it is,
to know it's even more real.
- [Iris] Yeah.
Yeah.
And how deep it is.
That's why I feel such a
passion here and for you,
it's 'cause I get to do
that, like help you--
- Reach more, I know what you're,
of course I know why you're excited.
- [Iris] Yeah, so.
Thank you, Gary.
(soft music)
- Vlog.
Iris and I just had a very
important conversation
and I'm gonna force her to share it.
(she laughs)
Sorry, Iris.
So, here it is.
We just did it ten minutes
ago or she just played it
and now I'm doing this part,
it's funny and I'll continue,
which was what I'm gonna say next,
356, rolling into Wine Library.
Once a year I take VaynerMedia New York
to Wine Library since it's close
and people do their holiday
Thanksgiving shopping.
It's a fun day.
It's kinda meshing my
two worlds so 90 or so,
almost 100 of the employees
are either here now,
are they here yet?
Do you know?
- Oh, yeah!
- They're here?
Oh, they came a while ago?
- [Iris] Yeah.
- Oh, awesome.
Anyway, nonetheless, bunch
of Wine Library people
here right now.
VaynerMedia people are here
right now at Wine Library.
Here are some of the highlights.
(soft music)
Here we have the man,
the myth, the legend,
guys this is Sasha Vaynerchuk.
He's the owner, founder, proprietor, CEO,
chairman of the board of Wine Library.
- Nice sneakers.
- [Iris] Thank you!
I love 'em.
- Yeah.
- Where are yours?
(Iris laughs)
(smooching)
What do you have to say to all
the young entrepreneurs, Dad?
What's a good piece of advice from you,
all the years of wisdom, being
a successful entrepreneur,
truly coming from nothing and building,
what's a good piece of advice?
- Good piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- Work hard and just keep
investing in what you believe
and have a lot of respect
for your fellow workers
who work with you because that's what
makes you more successful.
- But why were you successful?
- I had nothing to lose.
(he laughs)
Let's start with that, really.
I had nothing to lose--
- Fine.
What about tenacity?
Do you think you just
willed it to success?
- No, I was determined to make it big.
- Tenacity.
- Not as big as you are.
- Well, I mean, nobody's gonna
end up being able to say that
when I'm done with this.
- (laughing) I know.
- [Iris] Awesome.
- [Gary] 'Sup, gang?
(chorus of "hi"s)
- Hey, hey!
Hey, hi!
Hey, how are you guys?
Hi!
You guys havin' fun?
- Yeah.
- This is my dad, Sasha.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- How are you?
Pleasure.
'Sup man?
How you doin'?
Chaser, how are you, brother?
- Everybody's of age?
- Yes.
- You sure?
(he laughs)
Hello!
- [Man] Hello.
I'll be right there.
(hands clapping)
(patting backs)
- You're doing a great job, brother.
- Thanks so much.
- I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you so much.
- Literally, for the
first person of my thesis
to be working out this
well, it's a big deal.
Because if it didn't work, and you quit
or he was like suck it
or I was like fuck this,
it would be different.
It's so important for
the first one to work.
(energetic music playing in background)
I'm gonna hire six more of
you in like six minutes.
(laughing)
That's the plan.
Seriously, I mean, look, I
think you're a special dude
but I think I get six
emails like that a year
and I'm gonna try.
People that are smart.
For you to be this smart
to take one step backwards
for 54 steps forward,
that's just fucking smart.
And it's so obvious, right?
It's obvious to you 'cause
that's why you're doing it
but it's obvious to me.
Do you know that Iris quit?
- [Sinan] Yeah--
- And then re, unquit?
- We talked about it.
(laughing)
- That's amazing.
But that's what it is, what?
Iris!
She quit.
- Oh.
- [Iris] Hey, Ray.
- And then she was like, but
then she was like, mm-mm.
- [Woman Over Speaker] Grant call 208.
Grant 208.
- Check eBay, let's see what's going on.
You gotta see this.
'Kay now go to, scroll down, completed.
- [Man] I remember.
- [Gary] And sold, okay.
Look what's going on there.
Okay, this is today.
This is today.
- I mean--
- 200 bucks.
This is 85 dollars.
200, 169, 210--
- Look, by now.
- Yeah.
- Right, like.
That's 13.
- This is just ridiculous.
- I should have bought more.
- Brandon, you made a huge mistake.
- I did.
- This is the best eBay
arbitrage we've ever seen
and it's my sneaker and we did it.
Type in, get rid of sold.
- You should put on this white--
- Type solder.
- How surreal is this.
Just, this literally looks
like some upper deck promotion.
Alright.
Brandon, give me
something to taste out of.
(bottle sliding)
(soft music)
My dad's default face is
my favorite thing on Earth.
- What is it?
- Who's it for?
(Iris laughing)
- Hey Wine Library email
list, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
former host of Wine Library TV
that I used to film in
this office on this table
and today's mega offer is the
Conn Valley 2015 Chardonnay.
Kyle's here?
What the hell is--
- [Iris] Elle and Anthony are here.
- And Lev?
What the hell are they doing here?
- [Iris] They brought boxes for the wine.
- [Man] For your wine club.
- That's awesome.
Alright.
I love how integrated
Vayner and Wine Library are.
- [Man] Gary, this is my grandma.
- Hello, Grandma!
- Grandma Z.
- Hi Grandma Z!
- [Grandma] Hi there.
- How are you?
- [Grandma] How are you?
- Good.
Happy holidays.
- [Grandma] Good, thank
you and to you too.
- Thank you.
- [Grandma] I hope you all
get some rest out there.
- We'll figure it out.
(laughing)
One day.
- Yeah.
- Have a great day.
Take care.
(soft music)
I mean, it's been an incredible ride
for the pedestal that the entrepreneur
has been given in culture,
in the modern culture
and I think what's cool
for me is I really think
I'm a real, pure-bred
entrepreneur, at the ultimate core.
There's, I've got the steak and the sizzle
and I think that's what
makes a great entrepreneur
and I just think it's really cool.
I'm so humbled to be
able to represent a thing
and a type of man and woman
and I take that responsibility,
a new, emerging feeling for
me is how good I have to be
because I've been given the opportunity
to be an entrepreneur that
a lot of people look at
and I think I am, a lot of
people are impressionable
when it comes to entrepreneurship.
And I think there's an enormous
amount of responsibility
I have to do it the right way
and so all these decisions,
all these marketing concepts,
things like the sneaker,
I take them very seriously,
never looking at the short term
and this was a good one.
I'm very happy about it.
I just, I have more humility than people
that should have it, you know?
It's just my gear, man.
Look, again, it's fun to do this with you
because you worked at and closely to,
obviously we're on separate offices,
but you know, you have a very
clear feeling of what I am.
I'm not fancy, man.
I listen, I think I'm great
in all those good things
but I also think I'm shit and who am I
to not engage with everybody on Twitter
at 1:30 in the morning if
the website's not working.
I want to, I respect and am humbled
by their attention and
admiration and interest
in buying something, and I'm
there to help and apologize
and I'm willing to do customer service
and I'm willing to be the CEO.
I'm willing to make 500
million dollar deals
and I'm willing to carry cases to the,
I mean I grabbed a shopping
cart today for somebody.
Like, it'll never go,
I came from zero, man.
I came from not a whole lot, man.
I was a 14 year-old stock
boy, you know what I mean?
Like I had to work my
summers, I've got work in me.
I'm not scared of work, I'm not fancy.
There is never graduating.
There is no graduating to the next level.
You release a sneaker,
the website's not working,
you go on Twitter and fucking
answer people's headaches.
The end.
I don't know if there's
anybody getting more
out of what they've got than me,
and it comes out of my humility.
Got it?
And so you won't get as
much as you've been gifted
with charisma and talent
and all that you have,
because you think you're
special before you are.
Alright, brother.
Take care.
Talk to you, buh bye.
Vlog, if Iris decides to use this,
you'll see the references.
Ada Vasquez, former employee of Vayner,
jumpin', doing his thing.
Rootin' for him.
Hope he wins.
What time's our ETA?
We're going to the Garden.
- [Driver] We're going straight to Garden?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
6:52.
(soft music)
- What up, vlog.
Big day today.
Heading into mid-November.
Shoe is launched and sold out.
Crazy what's going on on the Bay.
Anyway, that's done.
Onto the next thing.
Big day at Vayner, just
a bunch of meetings.
Was fun to stop by at
Wine Library for an hour.
Good to see my pops.
Sure that's gonna be good content.
And now going to the Knicks
game with my brother AJ.
I'll try to get a little something for you
to end this episode with so this is almost
the ending of the episode
but good operations day,
got a lot done, bunch
of important meetings
with a bunch of big brands.
Lotta good stuff.
And, you know when you're feeling it?
Like you just know what
you're doing is right?
Today's one of those days.
Just that balance of steak and sizzle.
Clark Kent and Superman.
Gary Vaynerchuk, Gary Vee.
Just livin' that double cloak life,
Jekyll and Hyde kinda thing is kinda rad.
But it's not like Jekyll and Hyde,
it's like, which one is the good one?
Hyde?
Who's the good one in Jekyll and Hyde?
Hyde, right?
The Jekyll's like the jackal.
I'm livin' that Hyde and Hyde life.
(energetic music)
(soft music)
(sports announcer commentating)